今日は弾み社長です私は今日
世界の常識を
カエル数々のユーチューバーそうそうしたこちらの飲み物を知ってますでしょうか
ちょ一層申せない人いないぐらいだと思うんですけどもめちゃくちゃからすぎるソース
とって超有名です多くのユーチューバーこれは罰ゲームとして扱いまたはドッキリとし
て扱いたくさんの人を苦しめてきた
翼を悪くもごっこ
work な調味料でございます本当には何回もダメでござるんですけどもう本当に
もう年か辛すぎてどうしようもないからもう大変の方になっちゃうんですけども一般の
人が舐めるとこんな感じになってしまいますどうぞ
[音楽]
はぁ
はい注油に見て分かったと思うんですけどももう言葉が発せないくらい本当に激しい
痛みに襲われてその痛みがしばらく続くというとんでもない状況になってしまいます
ですがこの
月早々うっああっ魔王この方法キカイダーで二走の女っていう状況になったとしても
ですねカラーとかそういう感じの中でそう
そう述べるんじゃないかという気はそれを皆さんにをしようと思います本当にもう
すごいよ別ソースを薄めようと思っていろんなものが出た人がいるんですけどもどれも
なかったんですよその中私が準備したのはこちら
奥釣り飲めたねこれ知ってる人いるのではないでしょうか
くすり飲めたねってやつがありますいちご味ですねこういうふうにお薬を飲む時に使う
やつなんですけども
くすり飲めたねはゼリータイプのオブラートになっております
[ __ ] x 位が嫌いな子どもたちがこのゼリー
薬を包むとおいしく薬を飲めるよっていうやつでございますそうお薬嫌いだよって幸
多いんですよね
奥センターで苦いんだろう二階おっ薬をすぐ飲めるってホントすごいことだと思うん
ですよ
ってことはですよ25
ライトから入ってほぼ一緒なんですよ両方をその下に触っ
なればいっしょなんでこのでっソースをおくすり飲めたねでこうブラーとすればここの
画像では多くせるって嫌いだよ
大丈夫よ市場ずのぷるぷるゼリーにお薬がつつまれるから
ツリーに子くん本当だって止めるとこれが u 2バージョンだから
裂創スって嫌いだよ大丈夫よ1バーチのぷるぷるゼリーにデスソースが包まれ
からするんごっくん本当だねえっつってなんて子ソースのめっちゃれてもこれで包んで
のんち毎晩も
ペース走する科学ない母落第デスソースを飲み込むことができるんですよ
画期的です早速やってみましょう入っては早速やっていきましょう
まずおつりを出します
[音楽]
a これ水じゃねゼリーじゃねぇ
もっとちゃんとした是非がいい
こういうのでこういうの大丈夫かはいこんなもんすねこれ大丈夫でしょうか本当に
こんなの助手席や絶対薄れます
苦いお薬もこれで述べますからね辛いのはも0スって伸びますかねえ
ブルー
載せていきます
わっっ
やっちゃったーー
こうっていう待ってこれもやばいなーはいつも別荘だちゃんと包まれているのでこれで
どんなに辛いお薬でも悟空すれば余裕ですいただきます
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ
はぁ
カーンはカラー
[音楽]
ブーム
me
[音楽]
goo
ん
プーペガール